There've been three big changes in the
family in the last generation.
First,
the definition of the family has
changed.
So we now have adoptive families,
blended families,
nuclear families living in separate
houses and divorced families living in
the same house.
Also,
we have women have flooded into the
workplace.
Two thirds of women now work outside of
the home.
And the last thing which we don't talk
about as much is that men have come
flooding into the parenting space and
dads are much more involved in families
and I think this new generation of
parents,
because they are much more active and
much busier technology work,
etc. They're much more interested in
solutions so that the old debates be
strict,
like the Chinese are blacks,
like the French are no longer satisfying
for them.
They want results,
they want to know what works and they
want to be able to do it in their
families.
I'm the father of identical twin girls
and my wife works and we were incredibly
chaotic.
We just felt lost and out of control.
We would turn to our parents,
but their experience was so outdated as
to be almost quaint.
We'd facebook our friends,
but they're just as clueless as we are
and then we went looking for results and
the traditional solutions just seemed
very tired and out of date and yet at
the same time that these family experts
were telling us the same thing over and
over again in every other area of
contemporary life,
from business to sports,
to the military,
there's all these new ideas about how to
make teams and groups work more
effectively and so I wanted to go out,
find out what those folks were doing in
their homes and then test those ideas
out with my own wife and kids and my
wife put one red line in the sand.
She said,
okay,
I'm willing to try new things.
I'm desperate,
but I don't want theory.
I don't want some academic telling me
what to do.
I want to know that real families,
we're actually doing these real things
that I'm willing to try.
There is this idea about families that
exists,
no place else.
We have our jobs,
we work on those.
We have our hobbies,
We have our bodies,
our relationships.
We work on those somehow.
There's this idea that that families are
just supposed to be,
it's supposed to be organic,
that kids come with their own
instruction manual or something,
but every parent I know doesn't feel
that way.
We feel like our lives are out of
control and if I could put it in one
headline,
I would say that as a parent I felt like
I was always playing defense and never
playing offense and yet there's all
these new ideas out there.
So if that's where the action is,
if the action is in business or in
sports or in some place else,
let's bring those ideas in.
If your family doesn't have this
problem,
fine,
don't take these solutions.
I'm sort of not wagging my finger and
telling people what to do.
I'm saying that we were desperate for
new ideas.
I went founding them and I found a lot
of them in unlikely places.
When I sat out working on the secrets of
happy families,
I made a vow to myself that I wouldn't
squeeze everything into a list of three
or five or seven things that you must do
to a happy family.
I'm up at you,
but I hate those lists.
I forget number two,
I disagree with number four and I feel
like I'm doomed.
One of things I tried to do was to put
200 new ideas in this book because it
would be very obvious that nobody could
do them all,
but if you pick three or five or seven
that works for you,
and it might be different than what
works for me or what works for my
sister.
I think you can have a happier family,
and to me the biggest takeaway is you
don't need some master plan.
You don't need some big new scheme
that's going to be hard to set up and
impossible to follow.
You need to take small steps and
accumulate small wins.
What's the secret to a happy family?